horror prognosen die zum glück nicht
eingetroffen sind von bis zu 6.000
corona intensivpatienten haben die
experten gewarnt anfang dezember war das
aber davon sind wir jetzt weit entfernt
zum glück wir müssen aber über diese
prognosen sprechen über diese falschen
prognosen über prognosen bei denen immer
vom schlimmsten ausgegangen wird anstatt
vom wahrscheinlichsten genau darüber
sprechen wir jetzt auch mit der
ehemaligen bundesfamilienministerin
kristina schröder die uns jetzt live
zugeschaltet ist frau schöner hätten
bekommen erst einmal würde ich gerne
einmal ihren tweet vorlesen den sie
abgesetzt haben dort steht kann
letztlich nicht beurteilen ob omikron
chance auf glimpfliche herdenimmunität
ist ich möchte aber dass das rational
erwogen und abgewogen wird und hoffe
dass auch politiker und wissenschaftler
die bisher noko wird ideologie anhängen
diese gedankliche offenheit hinbekommen
wer die erste frage an sie was läuft
falsch
naja ich habe erst mal vor allem
hoffnung formuliert das so wenn ich die
internationale debatte war nehme merke
ich schon dass dort omikron teilweise
auch als als chance angesehen wird als
chance
um das bei omikron in seinem vermögen
verläufen offenbar so viel milder ist
dass wir deswegen mit nikon die chance
haben in einem zustand zu kommen der
video wie die krippe ist oder vielleicht
sogar wie eine erkältungskrankheit
das hieße aber dass die zahlen ansteigen
aber dennoch in den intensivstationen
zum glück gar nicht viele schwere
verläufe annehmen und das wäre eine
chance aber das müssen wir dann
natürlich in der wissenschaft in der
politik hier in deutschland auch so
wahrnehmen und dann abwägen ob wir daran
vielleicht unsere maßnahmen anpassen
aber sie sind jetzt einer der ersten die
diese entwarnung war sie ausspricht
ansonsten wird mit micon sehr viel angst
verbreitet ich kann die entwarnung ich
aussprechen kann das letztlich nicht
beurteilen ich kann nur sagen gibt
international diese debatte und ich
erwarte von den wissenschaftlern und von
den politischen akteuren dass sie sich
das angucken und dass sie auch diesen
weg rational erwägen und da das fordere
ich deswegen so so deutlich und klar
weil ich da schon eine gewisse skepsis
habe das hören sie schon richtig raus
wenn wir haben gerade in denen bei den
wissenschaftlern die für die
bundesregierung maßgeblich auch
expertenrat sitzen haben wir einige die
sich in der vergangenheit als anhänger
der radikalen logo wird ideologie
bekannt haben und nur co wird ist
natürlich das genaue gegenteil davon
unter umständen eine milde variante des
corona virus ist zuzulassen logisch sagt
er das genau gegenteil da sagt wir
müssen jede infektion unterdrücken und
versuchen in einen in ein stadium zu
kommen wo wir praktisch keine infektion
haben ich sage logo wird ist ein
attraktives ziel aber in der
verwirklichung müssen wir damit die
freiheitsrechte von menschen über wochen
über monate vielleicht sogar über jahre
derart massiv einschränken dass ich das
für eine letztlich totalitäre ideologie
halte und wissenschaftler die sich zu
dieser ideologie bekannter von denen
fordere ich jetzt gedankliche offenheit
sich auch auf diese internationale
debatte über die chancen von omikron
einzulassen das sehen wir ja dass das im
moment in anderen ländern passiert
gerade also dass großbritannien gerade
nicht damit reagiert jetzt mit
schärferen maßnahmen sondern dass man
die quarantäne regeln lockert das selbe
ist in südafrika passiert erwarten sie
genau das jetzt auch in den nächsten
tagen zumindest oder nächsten wochen
da weißt du gar ein bisschen positiv
überrascht wir haben hierdurch auf diese
debatte über locker irgendwann kantine
maßnahmen auch schon in deutschland
auch markus söder der sich ja sonst
immer damit hervortut die allerhärtesten
und aller drastischen maßnahmen koste es
was es wolle zu fordern hat hier ja doch
schon in diese richtung argumentiert
also ich glaube auch dass wir in diese
richtung gehen müssen das infizierte
zumindest ein paar tage in quarantäne
gehen müssen das denke ich es wird
erstmal so bleiben aber wir müssen mit
den kontakt garantien sprechen über die
kontakt quarantäne von menschen die
einfach nur infizierten über begegnet
sind ob die mich vielleicht zum beispiel
durch tägliches testen substituieren
können
frau schröder anfang dezember wurden
absolute horror prognosen angestellt das
hieß dass die intensivbetten belegung
auf bis zu 6000 steigt dass es zum glück
nicht eingetreten aber genau diese leute
die diese prognosen angestellt haben
prognostizieren auch weiter horror
zahlen für den januar deswegen haben wir
jetzt unsere kontakt beschränkung was
macht das mit ihrem vertrauen in
prognosen in modelle in das robert koch
institut
also mir fällt schon auf dass wir gerade
in deutschland einen besonderen hang zu
diesen besonderen negativen szenarien
haben und machen sich erinnern das
robert koch institut hatte vor einer
woche eine drastischen harten sucht
orten lockdown gefordert
selbstverständlich auch
schulschließungen auch für den januar an
aller erster stelle das fällt uns in
deutschland ja immer als erstes ein und
jetzt sehen wir diese harte lockdown kam
nicht dafür bin ich der ampel
bundesregierung durchaus dankbar und
dennoch sehen wir dass die zahlen jetzt
deutlich sinken und auch die zahlen auf
den intensivstationen was ja auch über
die weihnachtsfeiertage ein doch relativ
unbestechlicher indikator ist und
deswegen muss ich sagen die seit dieser
hang zum worst case szenarien die sich
in der vergangenheit oft als falsch
erwiesen haben und dann gleichzeitig die
politik die diese szenarien auftrat um
möglichst harte maßnahmen zu
rechtfertigen das ist eine ungute
mischung die wir hier in deutschland
haben oder verfüllt dazu dass
beispielsweise universität oxford
die iren die die härte von maßnahmen
beurteilt hat sagt die maßnahmen in
deutschland sind weltweit die
zweithöchsten auf der ganzen welt ich
finde schon darüber müssen wir reden
aber wie gehen sie denn ganz persönlich
um wenn die neue nächste warnung von vom
robert koch institut kommt 5 nach 12 10
nach zwölf halb eins und dann unterlegt
mit bestimmten zahlen sowie philipp das
ja gerade gesagt hatte anfang dezember
als man da von
5700 corona patienten auf den
intensivstationen ausgegangen sind wie
gehen sie damit um oder wie wir sie
damit umgehen wenn sie regieren würden
weglegen zur seite legen nein das kann
man ja nicht also ich persönlich muss
schon sagen dass meine
dass man glauben an diese prognosen von
prognose zur prognose schwindet und auch
realistischer und panischer der unterton
ist umso weniger vertrauen habe ich auch
denn dann habe ich immer das gefühl da
steckt eine agenda dahinter möglichst
harte maßnahmen durch sind wird man dass
es nicht die aufgabe der wissenschaft
die aufgabe der wissenschaft ist
sachlich über die über szenarien zu
berichten da gibt es immer mehrere wenn
es die zukunft betrifft und dann muss
die politik abwägen was sie daraus macht
und muss auch alle anderen folgen von
maßnahmen beispielsweise soziale folgen
psychische folgen folgen für kinder für
familien und sie auch mit in die
abwägung einbeziehen das ist die
aufgabenteilung und das haben wir
zwingend in der pandemie etwas verlernt
ein müssen wir wieder zurückkommen
frau schröder das vertrauen in das
robert koch institut das hat nicht nur
bei ihm gelitten sondern auch beim
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach auch
bei bundeskanzler olaf scholz denn die
haben in der vergangenen dekade wirklich
abgerechnet mit diesem alleingang von l
t chef lothar wieler der ja auch
hauptverantwortlich ist für diese schott
prognosen was glauben sie ist lothar
wieler noch haltbar in seinem amt
es wird mir hier seiner prognose ganz
besonders gestört hat ist es eher darin
einige
wissenschaftliche aussagen macht da kann
man ja sagen das ist seine aufgabe aber
auf der anderen seite vermischt er das
hat munter dann auch mit politischen
aussagen gesagt man soll die schulen
schließen das ist eine politische
schlussfolgerung die ihm schlicht nicht
zusteht und da muss ich schon sagen war
ich sehr erstaunt ist ein chef einer
behörde so etwas machen ich kann nur
sagen ich als bundesministerin wenn ein
chef einer von mir verantworteten
behörde ohne absprache von mir zwei
stunden vor einer entscheidenden
konferenz zu diesem thema das mal eben
nach außen gegeben hätte ohne weitere
absprachen mit politischen forderungen
die ihm nicht zustehen also ich glaube
bei mir wäre dann nicht mehr
gesellschaft gewesen klare aussage von
der langjährigen
bundesfamilienministerin kristina
schröder hierbei bild lei 40 größe zu
ihnen nach hause kommen sie gut ins neue
hatte dafür danke ja